I'm gonna play a clip for you now of
Arizona senator Wendy Rogers saying that
right now yes December 2022
Carrie lake is the governor-elect of the
State of Arizona now of course Kerry
lake is not the governor-elect of the
State of Arizona I think you probably
know that but what is fascinating about
this is
I don't think Wendy Rogers really thinks
Carrie lake is the governor-elect of
Arizona and I don't think Stephen Bannon
who's conducting this interview really
thinks Carrie lake is the governor-elect
of Arizona what's fascinating is about
this is that it seems to just be sort of
like a power game
does Bannon have the power
to get Wendy Rogers to say something
that they both know of course isn't true
who wields the power in this Dynamic and
it seems that it's Bannon take a look at
this this is unbelievable the problem
and uh we need to get to the bottom of
all of this and I just telling you we're
not having it anymore we're done as
Kerry said
as Kerry said you're messing with the
wrong people
[Music]
is Kerry Lake the governor elect of
Arizona yes
is there any doubt in your mind
[Applause]
you have an even stronger mandate and
she told me about a week ago she said
you know Wendy
um
by the way if you're watching this
bannon's co-host is so bored she's just
texting on her phone when I might have
assumed office had I been elected
properly without all this aftermath
maybe we would have had a honeymoon
period with everybody maybe we would
have had a transition time of you know
let's all get along
no all right no that that ship sailed
okay so what we're doing now is we're
going to in the Senate and in the house
we're going to legislate and then we
will work with her to get it all done
and people ask me oh Senator will you
take a meeting for this or that I go no
not until I know who the governor is
amen
so of course maybe this is evidence of a
Multiverse insofar as maybe maybe there
is a parallel universe in which Kerry
lake is the governor-elect of Arizona
but the universe you and I occupy is not
one in which that is the term that
applies to Kerry Lake you know you can
uh pray to Jesus Wish Upon a Star pull
out a Ouija board get a divining Rod
start chugging Homeopathy I don't know
you could do whatever you want Reiki
um it's not going to make Kerry Lake be
the governor-elect of Arizona
um at another point during this very
same interview
Steve Bannon and Wendy Rogers call on
people to get themselves arrested over
Kerry Lake's election I should not throw
out right this was intentionally done to
suppress the vote of Cary Lake
supporters and mega voters in Maricopa
County on Game Day correct yes and so
we're talking what we what I want to see
is people arrested right
very strong arrests
do you think do you think uh Colonel
Rogers would be like Judge Roy beam
right she's a hanging judge right get
some error I should not throw out right
unbelievable stuff and by the way
when someone like Bannon gets arrested
which by the way happened
he's got the money for a great legal
defense and they're gonna make it so
that he goes to you know the cushiest
prison and all this different stuff when
the people that watch this crap
follow the advice and they go out there
and they get themselves arrested they're
the ones that get stuck in pre-trial
detention they're the ones with the
public defenders and
public defenders can be great they're
just totally overworked and they don't
they just don't have the time to devote
to all the cases that are handed to them
and all these different things they
don't care about you at that point in
time and Marjorie Taylor green will make
a show out of going to visit you at some
jail and saying it's also unfair it's
unfair it's unfair but your experience
when you get arrested on their say-so is
going to be very different than their
experience when they get arrested one
other sad slash funny moment
um is just that this this co-host in the
pink dress on the right of the screen
she just is so bored with everything she
just texts the entire show look at her
unseat Rana McDaniel because she's
failed us okay real quickly give us that
again you've got to get
to get with the precinct committee man
your Precinct chair and and make sure
eventually you get up to the two
committee there's one committee man and
committee woman for each state correct
yes there's a committee woman in
committee state but the thing listen if
I was sitting there listening to Steve
Bannon dronen about this I've I'd
probably be texting someone as well but
just a horrible pathetic but also
extraordinarily dangerous situation
they're just straight up lying Carrie
Lake not the governor-elect of Arizona
she's not going to be governor of
Arizona for now maybe she'll run in the
future maybe she'll win in the future
but right now Katie Hobbs won thankfully
Katie Hobbs is going to be the governor